you made out with top not to be corny
but when I saw you in person
you were perfect things got steamy
during the groupie championship on the
mast singer and we didn't know this was
possible but Judge Ken Jong's head got
even bigger
I know exactly it ain't Halloween but
guest judge t-pain damn near saw a ghost
oh my god Chester Chester Chester all
that plus our special guest Margaret Cho
aka the poodle on unmasking the masked
singer
well we don't have a ghost with us
tonight even better we have a comedy
legend and a lung from the masked singer
everybody please welcome Margaret Cho
yeah I mean you crushed it on season one
thank you
your costume was so fierce and inked I
loved the costume yes yes we're gonna
ask you to stick with us tonight give us
all your Intel and share some of your
guesses if you don't mind yeah but
before we get into all of that let's go
ahead and take a look at tonight's
heartbreaking elimination
[Applause]
[Music]
it's Tom
it's Tom we've been saying it for a few
weeks now we have we predicted this from
the get-go now Margaret you did Dancing
with the Stars yeah did you know this
was your buddy Tom no but I love Tom he
is hilarious and such a great singer I
didn't know he had a great voice like
that you know it's just it was really
throwing me because this this particular
I was like I know I know them I know I
know them and I'll do i how how and it
really was getting to me that I really
could not figure it out but he just did
great and you know he's such a fun he's
such a fun person and I'm just glad I'm
glad that he was doing this is such a
different sort of thing of like for us
to see him it right will you mention
you're like I didn't know he could sing
it to him entertaining us and making us
laugh but this guy has a true like Frank
Sinatra yeah balladeer voice well he
kind of comes from this era of showbiz
that is like you have to be good at
everything you know and he really is he
can do so many different things and he's
such an a really smart performer and so
he made great song choices which I think
is the key to the show is that you
really have to you know pick songs that
fit your voice but also hide your
identity this is why t-pain was such a
great yes first season winner because he
really picked songs that nobody would
think that he would pick yes Sam Smith
didn't just hear some painting in that
and you know the range and the depth and
the richness that he would bring to the
songs was really it was really deepen
and so that's I think that that's also
part of the way Tom worked it he just
picked songs that you would never
picture him see sure well look week
after week we've dissected these clues
we did say tom bergeron from the get-go
i want to establish a few of the clues
we got tonight that further led us to
believe that it was Tom so we got these
really cool bonus clues tonight when
they were doing the fun on collaboration
performance at the top the tacos was
I've enjoyed a lot of salsas in my time
right so really really brilliant I'm
sure there yeah obviously like the
literal salsa but also of course he's
known for Dancing with the Stars going
to get many cells as every single week
also got another additional clue tonight
we saw the contestants give a a bracelet
with a clue on it to the judges so take
a look at what the taco gave Nicole well
to my friend Nicole not to be corny but
when I saw you in person you were
perfect what could it mean well we
figured it out Nicole obviously
performed on Dancing with the Stars and
rightfully won her season and during
week nine she did dance to Prince's kiss
so I think we yeah the case on there we
sure the perfect score which has never
happened on Dancing with the Stars
that's very difficult to receive a
perfect score so that I think that was
what it was 1,000% and Nicole's abs are
a wonder to behold take a look
[Music]
[Applause]
so that must have been the meaning of
the washboard yes do the wash washboard
abs the washboard clue just going back
to Nicole and right and washboard abs
yes that's a great are you in Tom in
touch are you gonna like text him or hit
him up ask him like this is crazy
you know I mean you know we didn't know
we didn't I didn't know he could sing so
beautifully but I guess this is a a
great a great feather in your cap are
you going what we asked you guys on
Twitter who you thought was going to be
eliminated tonight and a lot of you are
actually voting for the banana mask but
that is not what happened the banana is
here to stay
and we actually now officially have our
group a and Group B champions who will
be moving on to the super 9 finalists I
can't believe we're getting so close
we're getting so close one more group to
unmask here we have Group C starting
next week but first we need to know
right meow who this Kitty is let's take
a look
[Music]
[Applause]
all right listen I have been tearing my
hair out mulling over Clues mulling over
research we have set someone different
every single week us the judges and the
internet do you have any ideas I really
don't know I mean this one I'm really
really stumped and I think every clue
just gets more confusing I can't really
help and also the body type you know
like I just it doesn't seem like there's
just something about the the kitty that
doesn't seem like it's the some of the
guesses like yeah you know I just yeah I
mean we've we've heard a whole amalgam
of names I'm gonna throw out Nicole
Richie tonight yeah but the body is like
because she's so I mean it they just
seem different I'm not sure exactly what
makes them different I think there's
something more I didn't know she's more
like a fairy sprite and then the kitty
is more a little bit you know kind of a
more of a womanly like
womanly shape I think but that gonna be
the costume Margret Cho body language
expert over here I want to get into the
clue package I'm gonna make my case for
Nicole Richie so the first thing I want
to call out is this green Rapunzel BFF
of course tonight we heard from all the
contestants friends or relatives or
family members and we met the Kitty's
BFF so take a look at the hair it's
really long that reminds me of Paris
Hilton obviously her hair is beautiful
long and blonde it is nothing like this
green mess but you know even the pink
shirt the usage of the word BFF Paris
Hilton had a show called you know wanna
be my BFF so that I was like okay maybe
we've got something going along there I
also want to call out in the Faberge egg
so I looked up if Nicole Richie is like
a collector or something well she's told
glamour UK in the past that she did
start buying them when she was just
eight years old she said she didn't know
what they were but she knew that her mom
liked them so she would go to this fancy
store in LA called Geary's and she would
charge them on her dad's bill and and
that was the end of her having an
account there because they're very
expensive yeah well I do know one thing
is that when we were creating the clue
packages when I was on
yeah most of the the the impetus was on
making sure that you were giving clues
that were not anywhere goo global
interesting so it's almost as if if you
find something online that is about that
it's likely that it's not the person
that you're thinking because you're
perfect it's too perfect and so whenever
they were asking for clues there they
would you know really explain like well
can you google this if I set of course
there could be things that fall through
the cracks yes
you can't nobody could know well there's
only so many things that we can pinpoint
to a certain celebrity right so the
other last thing that I want to call out
is we saw in the clue package the woods
and a knife and the best friend said
whether she's writing poems or directing
horror movies that we would star in
she's always had a flair for the
dramatic no Nicole Richie has not
starred in any horror movies but she has
an interesting twist to Jordan Peele so
Jordan Peele put out the movie us last
year and he actually revealed that the
opening scene of the movie which
includes like a vintage 80s commercial
that commercial starred a very young
Nicole Richie oh so they had this very
bizarre take on it and even the fact
directing horror movies that directly
means Jordan Peele right I mean I think
that that is actually a good lead I mean
but when it comes to Nicole I just
you're not buying the body he's such a
person like a sort of a celebrity that
now is sort of very dedicated to behind
the scenes like she is like a mom and
she's like a designer and so she's like
that was last week's clue package you
know all the kitties sitting at the
sewing machine so we're like oh she has
a line called House of Harlow the last
thing that I want to call out for Nicole
Richie and I'll let you take the lead on
your guest is can we throw up the two
photos we have a photo of the kitty
costume and we have the photo of Nicole
Richie on her book cover I'm sorry
Margaret do you think these crowns look
alike they do look alike I also like
what are the of although the alternate
colored eyes that's got to be a clue to
like where is what does that mean but to
your point earlier I thought that was
too obvious like looking up celebrities
with two different other eyes so maybe
like two different
maybe two different kinds of identities
like as a celebrity and as a mom as a
designer as an actor okay so you know
what who's done multiple things but also
like I've never thought of her as a
musician but I guess because of her her
family that that's probably something
that you know most people who can sing
have family members who can say yes so
well I do want to let you know that a
very young Deidre Behar in high school
was a huge fan of Nicole Richie when she
put out a song called dandelion it was
never actually officially released but
it's still kind of floating around on
the Internet nikka listen
[Music]
so an OG simple life yeah so listen
we're we're grasping at straws here
we've said so many different names I'm
going with Nicole Richie this week who
are you going so I am going with the
popular vote online for Jackie Evancho
so you might remember her from America's
Got Talent very young came out with a
beautiful opera voice that did not sound
like one from a child well she has since
grown up obviously and people are really
pinpointing these clues to her so we did
see a chandelier this week in the clue
package the chandelier could allude to
her choice to consistently sing Phantom
of the Opera songs on America's Got
Talent she's also also covered a lot of
him on albums as well a few weeks ago we
actually saw the Pirates in a clue
package well she started entering talent
competitions between 2008 and 2010 and
she's saying the u.s. national anthem
consistently at Pittsburgh pirate
baseball games that's a tie that's a tie
there there's a few more obviously on I
think the whole growing up and being
seen in a different light is a big part
of it we talked to a one girl to a woman
and I think the kitty is giving us
something different and I'm kind of
sticking with Jackie Evancho I'm
agreeing with the Internet you know
there are you can make a 1000% valid
case but Jackie Evancho but this is the
hardest costume we have seen on this
show yet truly I am just like we usually
have a pretty decent idea of who's
behind mask I'm so stumped you've done a
good case for everyone I mean I really
do think like if it's between those two
then I would probably go with your guest
with Nicole just because of the idea of
like okay well who is this person that
would be performing on a show like this
that sort of makes sense to me because
they they are sort of thinking about
like show business families like what's
like rumer willis whether it's you know
or like a jackson oh yeah like that kind
of thing of like let's do the dynasty a
famous family yeah that's kind of a big
part of it and so it's just it's so
tough I mean that's why it makes this
show so great and then you cannot figure
it you know they leave us stumped so
many so many weeks after week on you
want to talk about the bonus clip yes
this bonus clue might make you think of
Jackie a little bit more we saw during
the opening group number
a small thing came on-screen and said
that the kitty is here to seal the deal
well could mean a deal in business could
also literally mean seals Jackie
performed for a few different charities
at seal events to support ending the
annual Canadian seal hunt also she was
in a PSA about baby seals who are
victims of commercial hunting and she
even made her own video series about
some work supporting the Humane Society
to fight against seal hunting with
nothing to do as far as that bonus clue
I've got nothing for Nicole but I do
want to talk about the friendship
bracelet that the Kitty gave to one of
the judges take a look
fireworks so I couldn't find any
evidence of like Robin Thicke and Nicole
Richie hanging out on the 4th of July
but you talk about family dynasty la
people who grew up with famous parents
yeah
no Kara Chi and Robin Thicke do have
history we do have a photo of them
together we do know that they're friends
and that they've hung out many times in
the past I figure she gave her bracelet
to him because they're pals they're long
time right I mean and you can't really
avoid like if you're the generation of
show business like give their parents
are in you're going to know each other
and so you're going to be yeah there's
going to be some relationship there so
that that's that's great information yes
we actually have two photos here this
was from 2011 at the Grove in Los
Angeles it was their Christmas tree
lighting ceremony Christmas trees guys
lit obviously there were probably
fireworks of some sort but Jackie and
Robin were both there that is a very
young Jackie but they were both there
and I'm assuming that would have been
the first time they met that's great
that's great too so there's a lot here
agree though we are head over heels for
our next performer take a look at the
banana
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
all right Margaret who is coming to mind
uh well I
at first we was sort of like sort of
think we'll Bret Michaels but then the
body's different so I feel like Bret
Michaels is actually got sort of a
broader chest I always look at the body
kind of like that's where I sort of
start Margaret on the physical but he
also Bret Michaels has a higher range so
the voice doesn't quite make me think
it's fret but you know you think like
well rock of love they drove in the tour
bus yeah yeah I love that show we're
gonna do some convincing we're gonna go
with our guests Bret Michaels let's take
it of course to the clue package we saw
the the people who gave the clues
tonight on the bananas behalf were two
girls two bananas yes and we know that
Bret is the proud father to two girls
rain and Georgia so that made sense and
you know they're very proud of their
father they said that he's such a great
role model and that he's been through a
lot of heartburn but has always been
able to laugh through anything now the
word heartburn triggered me so I thought
it could mean heart ache Bret has been
in many public relationships with either
Pamela Anderson or even they're the
daughters mom Christy Lynn Gibson or
meaning number two it could literally
mean heartburn like health issues we
know that he suffers with type 1
diabetes and he also suffered a brain
hemorrhage in 2010 that's right so very
very serious medical issues but he's a
guy with like a really big bright
presence and such a great sense of humor
the other clue that really triggered me
if we can throw up the racetrack clue
we saw the banana having the best time
ever on the go-kart there the girls said
that when we were younger the banana
taught us how to drive by building a
race track in their backyard and guess
what we have some visual evidence of
such a race track Oh on Bret's YouTube
account we see there a video of them
having some fun out in the middle of I
don't know it looks like they live in a
very kind of desolate area or you can
have go-karts appear back yes won't be
too for me were a little different we
saw a bottle of jam and a spider if we
can throw those up they're very small in
the corner clues when we saw the bananas
they're circling
well jamming with friends was Bret
Michaels last album to come out in 2013
jam tracks ok with friends also this is
now three weeks all three weeks we have
seen some sort of venomous animal in all
the clew packages so the first week we
saw a pufferfish the second week we saw
a snake and now a spider this kind of
all allude to poise of course exactly
that it's almost too obvious that like
there's so much of that that sort of
points to it it's it's like how can that
be but he what really makes sense is
that he is also a person that loves to
compete yeah he loves to compete
he loves this kind of thing you know
Celebrity Apprentice whatever he loves
this yes world so this is like a perfect
venue for him so I mean I think that
really sort of seals it women more than
anything yeah he's a guy who loves doing
these competition show more to really
seal it we got that bonus clue during
the opening performance and for the
bunny on it said what's more inspiring
than doing laundry well with a quick
search online you can actually find out
that in an interview with vh1's behind
the music Brett miles revealed that Bret
Michaels revealed that the inspiration
for every rose has its thorn came one
night when he was in a laundromat does
genius strike you at the most random
place I think that it's something that
like you you it can it can occur in the
most you know mundane situations and
then you have to your responsibility
it's a songwriter your responsibility to
record it or put it down yeah sometimes
you just think Oh that'll that's nothing
yeah it's actually could be great well
that was like his biggest hit
who knew laundry bags are great song of
course the friendship clue was equally
telling take a listen
my bracelet it's Virginia love
I'm just gonna say we had a little
chance to hang as friends oh sure sound
like a little morning had a great time
and I love you you're an awesome person
oh listen you love your 90 shows what
are you thinking I'm thinking that Jenny
McCarthy host have singled out you know
Playboy queen of MTV Bret Michaels a
really visionary artist of the 90s they
had to have cross paths at some point
the headbangers ball that kind of thing
like it like ricky rock booze cat house
you know there's a go I'm sort of like
Sunset Strip kind of interaction I
definitely you know they know each other
of course at some point or another yes
well and our final performance on show I
take a look
[Music]
alright I'm sticking with my guns we're
gonna keep with bow-wow bow-wow what do
you think I think that's a really good
guess I also would say Tommy Davidson
just because I think that again its body
shape and dance moves and showmanship
also foul well I mean it could be either
one yeah I mean they're both very
talented guys so greatly I really know
bow-wow as someone who is a musician and
dances a lot if we take it to the clue
package we heard tonight from someone
who's worked really closely with Bow Wow
I don't know if it was his mom or
perhaps a former manager someone on his
team in some capacity they say that this
person looked out for who we think is
Bow Wow
when he was in LA even when he had an
entourage
now that word is very pointed their
entourage
well of course Bow Wow was a recurring
star on Entourage and get this little
twist he played a character that was
trying to land a TV show and they
threatened that Nick Cannon was going to
replace him
Wow so very very mad I also want to
throw up the image we saw of the shampoo
bottle and the comb so I was like oh is
this someone maybe in the beauty
industry like what's going on well of
course Bow Wow he posted on last summer
that he not only has the top-selling
do-rag line but he's also planning to
put out a wave control brush and some
pomade oh good so he's getting into hair
care this is another clue which I think
I mean it that's that's very solid I I
think good margaret's by it I like I
mean it's just because I think like but
for me there's something that is like a
little bit older than Bow Wow about the
way that to this the the Frog sings and
perfect presents but that that maybe
just could be the fact that he's grown
up yeah yeah you know now he's an adult
and so we sort of see him as a younger
person but you know he's gray he's very
grown-up well I thought the friendship
bracelet also helped us out here a
little bit so take a look at that
girlfriend people
[Applause]
it says oh do is win so all I do is win
is obviously DJ Khaled's track so they
threw Ludacris his name out there
because he is featured on as a
collaboration but I'm still sticking
with Bow Wow because Bow Wow and t-pain
who he gave that bracelet to have
collaborated in the past you buy it yeah
I think that's I think that's good I
mean I think that it's somebody that is
definitely very very very much like deep
in the music world like he knows what
he's doing as a performer he knows how
to sing he knows how to dance he knows
how to present also this is like a very
very skilled performer a longtime
performer even though he's young unless
he's Tommy Davidson so now that you've
had like a couple has it been two years
yes yes are people still coming up to
you in airports and malls being like
they love the show and it's it's quite
iconic in its own like sort of Lane like
it's there's nothing like it and it
really brings everybody together when we
can't agree and there's so much stuff to
watch we can't agree on anything but
everybody agrees on this show it's just
like we're obsessed we stand we stand
yeah I love it we have heard from some
former contestants that there are a few
song requests they wish they had the
chance to sing are there any songs that
you put in that you didn't get to say
what I would have sang if I had not left
the sheriff I hadn't been voted off
would have been my cue next one where
you ought to know
and take me to church by hozier good
choice the other two that I would have
done but at which and those I was
actually nervous to do them because
there was such big choices the big songs
but to me I felt like oh well this is
worth it because it's such a you know
it's such a big show and such a fun
thing to do can we put you on the spot I
love it all star listen you seem like
you had such a fun experience doing the
show yeah I know you've got so many
celebrity pals are who are you
convincing anybody like
you gotta go do this oh yeah a lot of
people very famous people who you would
love to see it been asking me and
they're like they're just like yes do it
then they're so you give us some name
I really can't because you that'll be so
obvious then they'll go back to this and
they'll be like well she said it'll pull
the receipts on us yes we will be a
receipt you don't want to be a receipt
it's like I don't I don't want to be a
receipt like I do but I don't we have
you here it's so exciting you're part of
the Netflix family tell us about where
we can see you and where we can check
about well I will be doing the Netflix
as a joke festival in May and it's very
exciting but I'm on tour right now with
my show fresh off the bloat all over but
I'll be in Houston this week and then
the Kennedy Center on Sunday and
Washington DC all over the place zero
seer she's a funny funny woman well next
week we'll be seeing all new costumes in
groups see we have the astronaut the
bear the night angel the Rhino the Swan
and the t-rex whoo I love it so much big
thanks to Margaret Cho one beer you are
so insightful we're gonna pay attention
to that body language yeah it's
important yes Charlie O'Keefe Deidre
Behar oh is that it was that
[Music]